I mean it looks realistic here's one
thing the men are doing right now man
weeps there's a growing trend for men
hair week so in college was really where
my hair line was in his prime I fresh
out had a beautiful hair line like
everything was looking good waves my
look just like Juelz Santana early
Dipset days where he had the dark Caesar
and a little chin strap and then
Judgment Day came the day that I
realized I was actually balding you know
that feeling when you get on a
rollercoaster ride and you get ready for
that big dip like that's what I felt in
the pit of my stomach every time I took
my hat off right here I look like Carl
Winslow and I'm just like yo
now I'm bald and I guess I'm kind of
curious to see what it would be like to
have hair for a couple of days only
problem is I'm not so sure what my
girlfriend is going to think no
absolutely not no not today not tomorrow
not never Zeus but just think about what
all this could look like with hair hi my
name is Tripp the barber and I'm here to
give Zeus his hairline back
[Music]
I feel like something's about to happen
to me the way you're like come on Denise
are you ready my heart is beating so get
ready for this I 1 2 3 I think it looks
good in the same let's make sure I say
that like it does look good it's just
not the man that I fell in love with so
but I'm happy that you're happy
[Laughter]
good I feel elated I was a little kind
of like not worried but um curious
[Laughter]
rolling out my hair definitely was a
challenging process because I felt ugly
like I didn't want to take my hat off
because I couldn't shave my head and I
didn't feel as well put together as I
normally am like that is crazy
that's real when I rock it again I
wouldn't do it because I have a perfect
shaped football head like my stuff is
already God got this arranged but if I
needed to do it I would do it 100% again
because it came out really well I would
and I was suggested for people who bald
is not an option I would definitely
suggest that they do it give
shot was definitely
[Music]